organspende betrug spektakuläre nasa
animation und das ozonloch ist so groß
wie schon lange nicht mehr
das sind nur drei der fünf themen in den
krieg zum top five news die erde auf der
wir leben ja die wird mit höchster
wahrscheinlichkeit in 7 milliarden
jahren von unserer sonne zerrissen
werden wenn in der astronomie von weißen
zwergen die rede ist dann meint man
ausgebrannte sonnen wenn eine sonne
ausgebrannt ist dann besitzt sie kein
wasserstoff mehr
der ursprünglich als energiequelle des
brandes auf dem gestirn biete alles was
die sonne dann noch hat sind ihre helium
atome alleine bilden diese dann nach und
nach eine kompakte und extrem schwere
helium atomkern masse die ausgebrannte
sonne geht dann immer weiter auf bis sie
sich ähnlich wie ein platzender
luftballons schlagartig wieder
zusammenzieht bei dieser plötzlichen
größe reduktion werden sämtliche
gesteine die einmal um die sonne
kreisten vom weg abgebracht nähern sie
sich später wieder ihre alten sonne
können sie der gewaltigen schwerkraft
kaum standhalten
so sehen es forscher der university of
cambridge sie haben im fachmagazin
nature über ein derartiges spektakel
berichtet im sternsystem double you want
45 +1 76 ein weißer zwerg mindestens
einen in seinem umfeld befindlichen
planeten insel sc physik journal wurde
von forschern an ähnliche astronomische
nennen wir es mal teufelskreis
beschrieben zwei sterne würden sich so
nahe stehen dass sie drohen zusammen zu
schmelzen
die gefahr bei einer solchen schmelze
ist bzw
das faktische ergebnisse ist ebenso eine
explosion die unglaublich ist durch das
very large telescope in chile beobachten
die wissenschafter den ort des
geschehens das sternsystem wie fts 25
experten trauen unserer sonne ähnliches
so ist sie einmal ausgebrannt könnte sie
genau das gleiche wie all die anderen
weißen zwerge anrichten im übertragenden
sinne würde das nicht nur eine bedrohung
für unsere erde darstellen sondern unser
ganzes sonnensystem würde im grunde
zerfetzt werden
wie unterscheiden sich eigentlich
geschwister wissenschaftler der
universität leipzig und mainz haben sich
mit 20.000 menschen in form von drei
bereits getätigten amerikanischen
britischen und deutschen umfragen mit
diesem thema auseinandergesetzt sie
wollten herausfinden ob und wie sich
geschwister tatsächlich unterscheiden
sind klare differenzen zu erkennen oder
ist das einzig und allein dem zufall
überlassen
frank salchow low geprägt 196 die noch
heute häufig vertretene meinung dass die
jüngeren im gegensatz zu ihren älteren
geschwistern rebellen sein das damals
von ihm erschienene buch hieß auch born
to travel die deutschen wissenschaftler
konnten im fachmagazin proceedings of
the national academy of sciences seine
annahme allerdings nicht bestätigen
zitat die effekte die salome beschrieb
haben wir nicht gefunden so julia rohrer
gefunden haben sie aber eine differenz
in der intelligenz der geschwister
zweitgeborene drittgeborene fürth
geborene und so weiter hätten eine
niedrigere punktzahl bei einem iq test
erreicht als die erstgeborenen
allerdings liege der unterschied bei
gerade mal 1,5 punkten julia rohrer
zufolge würde das resultat ihrer studie
auch nicht beweisen dass die
erstgeborenen immer intelligenter als
der rest der geschwister sind
zusammenfassen könnte man also sagen es
spielt weder für die persönlichkeit noch
für die intelligenz der kinder eine
rolle in welcher reihenfolge sie zur
welt kommt schwarze löcher sind und
bleiben vorerst nahezu unerforschten
phänomene im all visuell wahrnehmen kann
man diese oft nur dann wenn sie gerade
einen stern oder ähnliches zerstören die
nasa hat dazu jetzt eine atemberaubende
animation veröffentlicht in der
animation kann man sehen wie ein
schwarzes loch einen stern aufsaugt
diese animation könnt ihr jetzt bei uns
in vollen zügen genießen
eine glasklare regel in der organspende
weder geld noch beziehung noch einfluss
noch macht dürfen die vergabe von
organspenden beeinflussen es gibt die so
genannte warteliste und daran muss sich
gehalten werden punkt ärzte das herz
transplantationszentrums der uniklinik
heidelberg haben da wohl gravierende
fehler begangen die die klinik selbst
zugegeben hat zitat es ist gegen die
regeln verstoßen worden so der leitende
ärztliche direktor di do adler in einer
stellungnahme teilte die klinik
folgendes mit die kommission hat bei
ihrem überprüfung auch gestützt auf die
untersuchung des universitätsklinikums
selbst bei insgesamt 34 patienten fehler
in der dokumentation festgestellt
insgesamt haben im untersuchten zeitraum
von 2010 bis 2014 121 patienten am
heidelberger herz
transplantationszentrum eine
herztransplantation erhalten
zitat ende die kommission von der die
rede ist ist eine prüfungskommission der
bundesärztekammer also da liegt einiges
im argen
bei den fehlerhaften dokumentationen
handle es sich um beispielsweise um das
verabreichen von speziellen medikamenten
in der stellungnahme ist die rede von
zitat der verabreichung bestimmter
kreislauf wirksamer medikamente zitat
ende adler der dieses verhalten wie eben
zitiert als regelverstoß sieht teilte
desweiteren mit dass durch das versäumen
dieser medikamentösen behandlung dem
patienten ein schnellerer zugang zu
spenderorganen ermöglicht worden wäre
moment also die haben patienten
bestimmte medikamente die ihm geholfen
hätten nicht gegeben damit sie in der
wahl am es ihnen schlechter geht und sie
in der warteliste nach oben gehen das
ist wirklich ziemlich fiese aktion sind
die patienten also zu ihren gunsten
benachteiligt worden
paradox aber genau das wäre der fall
sind andere patienten dadurch
tatsächlich benachteiligt worden
fragen über fragen
kann sich jemand von euch noch an den
großen aufruhr erinnern als das erste
mal von einem ozonloch die rede war
wahrscheinlich eher nicht das war
nämlich 985 vor genau 30 jahren
verursacht wurde es damals durch
chlorierte kohlenwasserstoffe kurz fckw
das gas das in sprühdosen und
kühlschränken damals war es wurde
verboten
doch hält sich sehr hartnäckig in der
atmosphäre fckw ist sehr langlebig das
ozonloch lässt viel zu viel uv strahlen
durch was unter anderem er hautkrebs zur
folge hat und in australien muss deshalb
besonders auf den sonnenschutz geachtet
werden
das land befindet sich direkt im
einflussbereich des ozonlochs in den
letzten jahren wurde kaum noch darüber
berichtet es gibt ja nichts neues
typisch journalisten was ist aber aus
dem ozonloch geworden aktuell ist es so
groß wie schon lange nicht mehr das
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
kurz dlr hat eine erschreckende zahl
veröffentlicht das ozonloch habe derzeit
eine größe von mehreren millionen
quadratkilometern genau 26 millionen
das ist das 72 fache der fläche
deutschlands
im jahr 2006 war sogar schon einmal 27
millionen quadratkilometer groß die
situation habe sich dennoch so im
schnitt gebessert aber so ganz gut
scheint es immer noch nicht zu laufen
wirklich gut laufen tut es auch für eine
psychopharmaka nicht es würde sogar
suizidgedanken auslösen mehr dazu
erfahrt ihr im video unter dem zur app
und zum block kommt ihr auch über das
wie und was sagt ihr zu der sache mit
den organspenden sollte man abwägen
dürfen also sich einen besseren platz
ich sag mal in der warteliste er kaufen
dürfen oder sollte absolut streng nach
der warteliste vorgegangen werden
lasst es uns in den kommentaren wissen
diskutiert darüber und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran